[Music]
this is a black-and-white ruffed lemur
that's a lemur yeah and you know what
Conan I'm actually just he likes to go
up to tall things and you're much bigger
than I am so let's do that you can just
let him shake your arms what is but in
my face let's see hey buddy come on
good job I feel like the lamest
superhero right now with control of his
lemur Lima free what you're doing right
now is actually just simulating where
these guys live they're arboreal that
means that they live in the trees these
are a primate so they're kind of related
to monkeys they live only on the island
of Madagascar and they're super
endangered all right his um his little
jelly treat here kind of flopped out
there so let's see let's see what he
does he's safe now try me to lower my so
go ahead and lower your arm and see what
he does okay every show you lower
yourself should I lower myself
he really likes having armpit scratch it
if I can get my hands you say these
things that end up not being true they
love it when you rub it belly
you know sealed in a pumpkin yeah they
love it when their Airways restricted so
rub
there we go okay right here yeah you got
it you got yeah that seems like that
he's calming down yeah he is those are
the eyes of a very calm animal
okay see how calm it is
[Applause]
so this animal is actually taller than
you
I'm suing you
but I'm assuming you know what it is
right yes that would be an ostrich
that's right yes I've heard those things
are there well are they dangerous that
this animal could actually kick you and
kill you go ahead put your arm out okay
like just like this just like that now
why would it kick me and kill me why
would it do that
okay this animal was threatened so out
in Africa let's say that in a strange
environment with someone who hadn't seen
Norwich environment now if he was
threatened thought you were trying to
attack it they can use those huge legs
with the huge huge muscles and those
sharp claws on the end and they could
actually kill a lion they can kill a
lioness so you wanna they get that close
to a lion
they wouldn't actually walk up to the
lion the lion would come after them but
they're really fast they can run over a
forty miles an hour
it's when it really it's not gentle the
way it eats out of your hand no it's not
it's not it's not it's a little bit
bigger than a chicken or you know duck
at the petting zoo but okay what's this
ostriches name right here you know
this ostrich does not have a name these
these guys remember we were talking
about ericone and we were talking about
eggs everything becomes there you go
just stay right here okay make it easy
for no you go back to the whole idea of
my brother at the Christmas table
Hey okay show these guys names because
they're wild animals there while they
don't give up what about what are you
talking about you can't name a wild
animal you can but again we want to
encourage people to name their pets
right dogs cats you don't want to have
obviously most people are not gonna have
an ostrich he's gonna they kind of
collect the food in the neck until
there's enough of it and neck is bulging
out again like my brother at a Christmas
table and it will go all the way down
into the the sort of multi-track stomach
system and if they're fascinating
animals every now and then he stops and
looks me right into my eyes yeah and
it's like almost like he's looking at me
and said oh god there's not too much
going on between those eyes there
they're not known to be the most he does
that every now and then it's sudden it's
unnerving
it's unnerving and it's like I remember
you just saw Andy